these remote-control drones are far more
maneuverable and also faster than
traditional model airplanes
Berlin is among the many cities with a
growing drone racing community yeah it's
a duster racing quadcopter diese this is
a quadcopter made for racing these
machines are not quite as agile but
they're super fast and designed to be
robust to handle the frequent collisions
I'm a gimbal geek and quad copter has
four engines which is where the name
comes from and in a middling effective
control motherboard is hit down the
center they go to the fence that there
are two cameras that's like come at us
einen and one recording the video hundra
and the other transmitting images live
to these goggles tonight so I can see
where I'm flying with it's called first
person view a concept originally devised
for radio-controlled model planes
the goggles allow the pilot to see
exactly what the copter is filming that
helps create the sensation of
experiencing the aerial stunts firsthand
but it does take some practice man futhi
Angli and you feel like you've been
transported into the copter on the first
two flights with the goggles I fell out
of my seat when I did banking maneuvers
don't you feel like you're moving with
the copter then it's like you're a bird
flying over the fields were demanding
for whom be duty do you must face see
you at Germany's first ever quadcopter
contest that a horse racing venue in
Berlin pilots treated on Lucas to some
real thrills and spills can guns entha
upside listen god helps to free your
mind they're flying with a bunch of
people is an incentive to fly faster and
the machines are designed for that balls
could have uh ladies freedom and they're
wrong in Formula One style the
quadcopters navigate their way around
the obstacle course at speeds of up to
130 km/h while their pilots set at
trackside in Germany and many other
countries thrown races in the open skies
require special advance permission from
the authorities there are a ready plans
for the first world championships in
Hawaii next year there'll involve around
300 pilots from around the world
competing prize money totalling 90
thousand euros
the larger models are better for
beginners still getting to grips with
drones
the event in Berlin included training
courses quadcopters are essentially
flying computers some of them fitted
with GPS and HD quality cameras
remote control is trickier than it might
sound but the apprentice pilots relish
the challenge yeah as a Viking I was
already into them and now I like them
even more I'm ready for the next step do
you wanna get my own drone as if you ask
the tunnels of the song it's just a
question of how as her partner knows
it's up the quadcopters have become a
hugely popular high-tech toy there's now
a wide range of versions on the market
mini-drones like this copped around 70
euros racing standard quadcopters are
often made by the pilots themselves
toshiba the Ottomans are you do need
technical know-how or a background in IT
so that you can program the flight
control i'ma tell you won't be able to
solder because of all the electronics
you can't get this in a store at this
man neither dinger in depth warm mist
then there are the special editions
which scale new horizons of creativity
but what they all have in common is
they're fun